l'actualité de ce mardi tourner
largement autour de l'ukraine d'abord le
sommet du g7 qui s'achève en allemagne
avec une condamnation unanime des pays
les plus riches mais aussi de l'inde
contre la russie bonjour bruno daroux on
vous retrouve en direct de garmisch
partenkirchen vous suivez ce g7 bavarois
depuis dimanche il est donc terminée
qu'en retenez-vous
alors écoutez évidemment pendant un peu
plus de deux jours les dirigeants du g7
ont parlé de beaucoup de dossiers donc
on va essayer de ramasser un peu
l'essentiel de ce qui a été dit qui a
été résumée par le chancelier allemand
olaf scholz dont le pays donc accueilli
cette édition du g7 d'abord vous l'avez
dit c'est bien sûr la guerre en ukraine
qui a mobilisé l'attention des
dirigeants avec un soutien renouvelé à
l'ukraine est une unité du camp de ses
leaders du g 7 skis emmanuel macron
appel le camp de la paix contre le camp
de la guerre le camp russe donc il faut
a dit olaf scholz que vladimir poutine
subissent les coûts de cette guerre
l'aide et le soutien à l'ukraine restera
entier il faut aussi penser à la
reconstruction de l'ukraine et olaf
scholz a réitéré sa proposition d'un
plan marshall pour cette reconstruction
autre axe important dans ce g7 à la
famine dans le monde qui est une des
conséquences de la guerre la crise
alimentaire concrètement le g7 des blocs
près de 5 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires pour venir à court terme
en aide aux pays qui sont le plus
affectées ce qui portera le total de
l'aide des pays du g7 à 14 milliards de
dollars sur l'année 2022 il faut
également lutter bien sûr contre la
hausse des prix de l'énergie et
l'inflation galopante dans les pays
occidentaux les pays en voie de
développement
alors pour cela il faut bien sûr réduire
la dépendance des pays à la russie
notamment en matière d'énergies fossiles
mais il faut à plus long terme arrêter
de financer ces énergies fossiles
pétrole et gaz et poursuivre le
développement des énergies renouvelables
enfin il faut rester engagés sur les
objectifs
à long terme du g7 notamment en matière
de lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique il faut donc accélérer la
transition énergétique des pays
occidentaux et plus fortement aider les
pays en voie de développement et puis
bruno emmanuel macron a tenu une
conférence de presse il ya quelques
instants le président français estime
que la russie ne peut ni ne doit gagner
la guerre il est aussi revenu sur la
tacc russe d'hier contre un centre
commercial dans le centre de l'ukraine
il évoque un crime de guerre on écoute
nous avons tous avec la plus grande
fermeté condamné ce nouveau crime de
guerre
et son atrocité
si besoin en était c'est la preuve une
nouvelle fois que l'armée russe
décidé d'utiliser
la sidération comme un élément du
conflit et s'attaquent à des civils
donc là aussi nous continuerons devrait
pour que la vérité soit faite et que
toutes celles et ceux qui doivent l'être
soit condamné par la justice
internationale et la justice ukrainienne
voilà pour cet extrait de la conférence
de presse bruno emmanuel macron parle
donc de crimes de guerre mais il ne
reprend pas les termes de volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien qui
parle lui de qui parle de la russie
comme d'un état parrain du terrorisme
oui emmanuel clairement emmanuel macron
par trop clairement ne veux pas entrer
dans ce genre de qualification ce n'est
pas notre méthode at il dit en revanche
il faut absolument que les crimes de
guerre et les auteurs de crimes de
guerre soient punis soit jugé mais c'est
à la justice justement la justice
ukrainienne et internationales de
qualifier ces crimes de guerre et la
situation emmanuel macro qui comme ses
homologues a été très dure avec la
russie qui ne peut ni ne doit gagner at
il dit et puis concernant les
conséquences économiques de cette crise
notamment la crise énergétique il est
revenu sur une idée dont on a beaucoup
discuté au cours de ce g7 c'est l'idée
de plafonner les prix du pétrole c'est
une très bonne idée a dit emmanuel
macron le problème c'est qu'il ne faut
pas simplement plafonné
prix du pétrole que les russes vendent à
leurs clients il faut élargir ce
plafonnement à l'ensemble des pays pour
que ce soit réellement efficace que le
prix du pétrole baissent et que donc à
la pompe est bien les citoyens de tous
les pays puissent remplir faire leur
plein d'essence avec des prix qui soit
abordable
donc c'est compliqué ces techniques ça
prendra du temps mais l'initiative
politiquement est en tout cas lancé et
puis emmanuel macron est également
revenu sur la situation alimentaire lui
aussi en disant qu'il fallait absolument
aider à court terme les pays les plus
impactés mais aussi penser à moyen et
long terme notamment en aidant les pays
en voie développement particulièrement
en afrique à développer leur secteur
agricole et avoir également un meilleur
accès à l'électricité par les énergies
renouvelables emmanuel macron qui a
rappelé que sur le continent africain il
y encore 600 millions de foyers qui
vivent sans électricité
merci bruno daroux envoyé spécial france
24 à garmisch partenkirchen
voilà donc pour ce sommet du g7 qui se
termine